the rock may be the biggest movie star
in the world but I bet you didn't know
how good of a business man he is as well
back in 2012 The Rock launched seven
bucks production which has become one of
the most popular movie production
companies in Hollywood then in 2016 he
did a partnership with Under Armor which
has led to tens of millions of dollars
of sales in 2020 he came out with Terra
Mana tequila which sold over 300 000
cases in the first six months and is
estimated to be worth billions of
dollars and then in 2021 The Rock
followed it up with the zoa energy a
healthy energy drink that's been flying
off the shelves you may know the rock as
a mega star on the big screen but he's
also a business genius